[Musique]
il
emmanuel de valicourt bonjour bonjour
vous merci d'être sur le plateau tv
soixante dix huit pour ce vide que l'on
va entièrement vous consacrez vous êtes
ici parce que vous avez écrit un livre
qui est sorti a pas très longtemps sur
livre là sur marie antoinette donc sur
la versaillaise janvier la plus connue
du monde
absolument il est tard et la reine de
france certainement qui le plus rester
dans la conscience des français on va là
exactement
alors on va déjà faire un petit peu plus
connaissance avec vous vous avez vous
êtes un jeune écrivain puisque ce livre
c'est votre deuxième
vous avez une profession vous êtes
professeur de droit et de droit
canonique à la catho absolument
voilà et vous avez j'ai bien
l'impression une passion pour la société
d'avant la révolution c'est ça c'est la
sociologie de la société
prérévolutionnaire je la trouve
absolument passionnante parce qu'en fait
il ya un enchaînement de faits qui sont
quand même toujours très surprenant et g
à travers cette laitue de cette
sociologie j'avais un peu envie de
comprendre pourquoi
l'enchaînement de ces fait d'accord
alors vous avez commencé à creuser la
faire avec une première biographie qui
était consacrée à charles alexandre de
calonne ce soir ministre des finances de
louis saez
c'est pourquoi cette alors j'ai pas dire
illustre inconnu enfin pour moi oui
illustre inconnu voilà dites moi
pourquoi lui et c'est sur que c'est pas
le plus connu des ministres des finances
de louis saez on connaît bien sûr
jacques necker qui restaient dans le
dans les mémoires calonne et un de ses
opposants politiques et économiques
en fait il se trouve que j'ai quelques
liens familiaux avec lui puisque sa
soeur je descende sa soeur et donc je me
suis interrogé intéressé à ce personnage
qui
sur lequel on avait véhiculé beaucoup de
poncifs et à partir de là j'ai découvert
cette société qui précède la révolution
que j'ai trouvé très intéressante et
j'ai décidé de creuser un peu plus doux
le livre que vous avez livre rendre à
l'aréna qui s'appelle les favoris de la
reine dans l'intimité de
marie-antoinette voilà et alors donc
calotte ça c'est fait et alors pourquoi
pourquoi marie antoinette sachant que
des millions de millions j'en sais rien
mais beaucoup de livres on est déjà été
écrits sur elle que vous êtes pas dit
tout a été dit c'est ça non parce qu'en
fait mon nouveau logis j'ai trouvé un
prénom un prisme sur lequel j'avais lu
relativement peu de chose qui est le
rapport de marie-antoinette aux hommes
on a beaucoup parlé de son entourage
féminin bien sûr tout le monde connaît
la duchesse de polignac et la princesse
de guéméné il ya la princesse de
lamballe
et puis il y à des hommes dans la
société de marie antoinette qui
gravitent autour de l'arène
bien sûr tout le monde connaît en 500
personnes selon le scénario de vitesse à
celui qu'on connaît le plus exact air et
mais il y en a un certain nombre
d'autres qui étaient en leur temps des
personnages tout à fait important et qui
sont un petit peu tombé à la trappe de
l'histoire et ça m'intéressait au
travers de l'étude de ces personnages-là
de creuser un peu cette question du
rapport de marie-antoinette aux hommes
on en a peu parlé d'accord alors ce que
vous faites très bien et vous faites
bien de le faire c'est nous replonger
vraiment dans le début de l'histoire de
cette jeune princesse de 14 ans qui
arrive de triche comme ça on a on a un
petit peu
l'idée que c'est comme comme dans la
fosse de la cage aux fauves
non oui la cage aux fauves la cage au
fusil pour hugues quand même allez pas
tellement préparés puis à la lâcheté là
à savoir 14 on est donc dans la première
partie et bien vous nous faites
ressentir vraiment son état d'esprit et
les situations qu'elle a affrontée
absolument c'est là la dernière fille
deux derniers enfants de la grande marie
thérèse la petite dernière elle arrivée
là 14 ans en france elle est comme tout
jeune et il faut savoir que les deux
dernières filles de l'impératrice marie
thérèse ont eu une éducation un peu
négligé est certes un peu d petite
pouliche qui ont été laissés au près
avec la ligue sur le coup et donc marie
antoinette dès son arrivée va être
confronté à une réalité qu'elle ignore
qui est en france le poids de
l'étiquette et l'étiquette en france
vous savez on la surnommait la machine à
rééduquer les rênes et donc
immédiatement elle se elle se confronte
elles s'affrontent même à cette réalité
et qui sera très dur pour elle très
difficile eh oui du fait de son jeune
âge et comme vous dites si tu es là pas
du tout était préparé à ce rôle et puis
alors du coup notre ami louis saez il
est un pas très présent non plus au
début non ils se marient à quel âge
quelle est la côte est se marient alors
elles se marient dès son arrivée à 10,14
absolument qu'elle était lors de son
arrivée et elle devient reine en 18 en
1770 c'est à dire que elle devient reine
en 1774 pardon et elle arrive en 1770
donc quatre ans après elle est dauphine
pendant quatre ans et elle devient reine
à la mort de louis 15 en 1774 donc elle
a 18 ans ah oui d'accord ok et de vous
ce jeune couple n'est absolument pas
préparés à renier non on est d'accord et
elle bat encore moi et elle a une espèce
d'inversion pour comme vous dites pour
tous ce protocole extrêmement pesant
c'est cela et puis elle découvre surtout
une coup
avec des arcanes de fonctionnement
extrêmement compliquée avec des luttes
d'influencé avec des ambitions parfois
contrarié qui se sont remplies dans le
ragot et dans le la médisance des
jalousies absolument terrible est ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que marie
antoinette arrive avec une nature très
fraîche d'adolescentes de 14 ans elle
est profondément bonne elle est assez
innocente elle est fraîche elle est
généreuse elle est gaie et elle va
s'affronter à ce monde un peu fermenté
de la cour versaillaise et savez je dis
dans mon livre
à versailles les gens sont entassés les
uns sur les autres
un peu comme des pommes dans un cageot
et qui finissent par pourrir car quand
on sert les pommes les unes contre les
autres
elles finissent par courir il ya ce
phénomène là à la cour de versailles qui
est indéniable et cette petite jeune
femme va découvrir cela douloureusement
à ses dépens et alors qu'est ce qui se
passe du coup on a l'impression qu'elle
se fait excusez moi l'expression mettre
le grappin dessus par une petite coterie
alors en fait j'en sais je sais pas fait
ça parce que en fait tellement elle va
elle même créé la situation c'est à dire
que face à cette ambiance un peu
délétère qui lui pèse
elle va chercher à se protéger dacourt
voilà elle était pieds tout le temps
elle détruit une grande partie de sa
correspondance parce qu'elle a peur
qu'on la lise l aile
cache ses clés de ces cabinets parce
qu'elle a peur qu'on s'introduisent pour
regarder ces affaires elle dit qu à
l'acteur tout à fait c'était à fait
fondée elle découvre un jour en ouvrant
la porte de son cabinet alors qu'elle
était en train de parler avec son époux
le duc de berry futur louis saez elle
découvre le duc de lavaux guillon à
genoux avec l'oeil dans le trou de la
serrure qu'elle sait qu'elle est épié
continuellement il s'agit en se
protégeant et en levure et
douloureusement et elle va comme vous
dit très justement s'isoler essayer de
se protéger ne se rendant pas compte que
ce faisant elle va s'exposer encore plus
à la médisance parce que plus moi l
adami plus elle admis ce soir voilà
comme ils ont tous en train de se battre
pour pour leurs propres intérêts et
avoir le maximum de faveur donc elle
s'est isolée et finalement elle s'est
mise en danger
c'est tout à fait ça vous expliquer et à
partir de là donc un certain nombre de
courtisans vont comprendre quel jeu
politique et courtisans ils peuvent
essayer de jouer auprès de cette jeune
dauphine et la foule a bien comment
l'utiliser c'est ça voilà alors et puis
aussi une autre idée qu'elle s'est un
peu mis en tête et king qui paraît pêche
jeux privat qui ne paraissent pas
vivable
c'est à dire qu'elle voudrait être elle
même oui elle dit au petit trianon je
suis moi menem ne peut pas être elle
même
c'est cela fait pire des dangers est la
marie antoinette à un désir qui nous
paraît tout à fait naturel nouveaux
modèles comme il y est là désir d'être
femme elle a le désir d'être femme
or ce qu'on attend d'elle en 1770
lorsqu'elle arrive en france et en 1774
lorsqu'elle monte sur le trône
c'est d'abord qu'elle soit souveraine
mais voilà et elle elle est là le désir
d'être femme elle veut bien être
souveraine avec parfois des réticences
sur un certain nombre d'obligations
institutionnel mais elle a aussi le
désir d'être femme et les les courtisans
qui vont créer autour d'elle cette
petite société restreinte vont lui dire
que son désir d'être femme est légitime
allah est canalisée dans cette histoire
ce qu'une particulière a le droit
d'avoir et elle va le croire
voilà et c'est là qu'est ce qui va
causer partie
finalement les opinions publiques et du
reste de la qos aveux alors ils te voilà
donc ça c'est très bien expliqué c'est
vraiment passionnant dans la première
partie de votre livre après il ya aussi
toutes les influences de sa mère oui qui
la bombarde lettre qui la tient comme ça
à distance d'une façon extrêmement serré
ce sens il ya ça il ya phonique du
question cathodique eux qui aiment quand
même très ancrée et ce qui fait que
finalement elle a beau avoir envie de
plaire et plaire d'ailleurs et jouer un
peu de l'ambiguïté elle en reste tout de
même très sage oui elle reste sage elle
reste sage d'abord parce que quoi qu'on
ait pu en dire
elle a quand même une vraie conscience
de ses devoirs dynastique
il ya une chose qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est que pour une reine de france
prendre un amant signifie prendre le
risque de mettre au monde un bâtard et
elle a suffisamment conscience de ses
devoirs dynastique pour ne pas prendre
ce genre de risque et puis elle est
comme je le dis dans mon livre une chose
qui a été relativement peu dit par
l'historiographie c'est que je crois
profondément qu elle est structurée par
son éducation catholique
de ce point de vue là l'impératrice
marie thérèse jouent un rôle très fort
un elle ne cesse dans sa correspondance
de lui rappeler ses devoirs en matière
de foi catholique et donc en plus le
louis saez d'abord le duc de berry puis
louis saez lui renvoie l'image d'un
époux fidèle
oui tout cela crée un créer un cadre
dans lequel elle sincère sans difficulté
et puis un détail aussi très important
et que tous les contemporains note c'est
que marie antoinette est une femme fière
c'est une femme fière qui ne
s'abaisserait pas pour la satisfaction
de sa seule libido à prendre un amant
d'accord rail à petit ça oui elle est au
dessus de ça vous avez jusque dans la
charrette des condamnés
je sais pas si vous le connaissez il ya
un petit croquis extraordinaire qui se
trouvait dans la collection en chine qui
représente marie antoinette dans la
charrette des condamnés
croqués par le peintre louis david
et les commentateurs qui voit la reine
passé dans la charrette des condamnés 10
sans miséricorde pour son malheur disent
regardez comme elle a encore l'air fier
et c'est vrai que tous les contemporains
disent que la reine est fier oui fallait
digne et remplit son rôle dignement son
rôle de mère d'envoi le dépouillent etc
l'histoire nous nous montrera alors on
va quand même évoqué le ils sont cinq
ses favoris on est d'accord on a donc il
y en a plus qu'une option de choix vous
avez choisi cinq dons qui gravite à tour
de rôle ou ensemble parce que c'est sur
une assez longue période finalement ce
sont ses proches
alors juste pour on va pas tout évoque
évidemment donc fersen pour lequel elle
éprouve et réciproquement un amour
platonique
non pas vraiment voilà et il y a aussi
le plus vous dit le plus pervers le plus
manipulateur qui est vaudreuil
qu'est-ce qui on peut donner un exemple
de sa nuisance à l'or aux jo de radio
vaudreuil est ce personnage ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que l'entourage de
marie-antoinette ce qu elle qu elle
adoube pour devenir ses favoris le terme
ne vient pas de moi c'est celui qui est
employé par les contemporains pour
définir ce cercle restreint dom en
général jeunes séduisant tous de belle
prestance et de belle apparence qui pour
la plupart d'entre eux sont des
militaires en pleine forme uniforme
exactement la reine aime beaucoup
beaucoup les uniformes c'est un peu là
pour la déco est là aussi on pouvait y
participent
obligé de révéler qu'elle a décidé se
former absolument
et elle à trianon elle a ce petit monde
qui lui plaît et ils font partie du
décor et en matière d'hommes je dirais
que de manière peut-être un petit peu
raccourcie mais comme pour ses meubles
comme pour ses porcelaines comme pour
son château comme pour ce sens en son
jardin
marie entonnait de voeux ce qui se fait
de mieux d'accord voilà
et donc elle est la double un certain
nombre de personnes et vaudreuil est
certainement dans ce qu'elle a adoubé
celui qu'elle a le moins apprécié mais
qui va introduire auprès d'elle celle
qui sera sa grande amie la comtesse
jules de polignac qui sera faite
duchesse de polignac voilà alors il l'a
à ses yeux cette grâce là elle est
localisée peut-être connaissance à lui
est reconnaissante de ça en même temps
elle s'en méfie beaucoup car elle s est
un peu calculateur d'accord très bien
alors on va on va arrêter par ce livre
parce que ces interminables c'est
passionnant donc on va laisser que même
les téléspectateurs
mais à la suite et découvrir bien sûr
moi je vous dis juste avoir votre avis
sur par exemple film de sofia coppola en
quelques mots et peut-être aussi sur les
adieux à la reine de
de benoît jacquot qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé de
alors rien tonnelle de sofia coppola
écoutez pour être très honnête décemment
ça m'a pas ça va pas furieusement tout y
est mais je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que en fait je trouve que alors
qu'il ya eu certainement des quantités
de conseillers sur le plan historique
pour les décors c'est absolument
merveilleux pour les costumes c'est
esthétiquement je pense qu'il n'ya rien
à contester sur la valeur visuel et
esthétique de ce genre de film et
maintenant on met un argent fou en tant
que ces réalisations est allé c'est
ainsi et c'est un bien mais je pense
qu'il ya une forme ce qui est pour
l'histoire à mon avis le péché capital
une forme d'anachronisme
c'est à dire qu'il ya une lecture très
21e siècle du xviiie siècle et je pense
que ça c'est un peu réducteur
alors évidemment lorsque l'on à une
heure et demie pour raconter toute la
vie d'une personne c'est un peu court
on est évidemment obligé de réduire et
puis et puis il faut bien sûr et de tout
fait sens et l'image qu'elle se faisait
lentement et puis il faut intéresser les
spectateurs dont je pense que c'est un
petit peu à la fois réducteur et
caricatural par certains aspects voilà
un séducteur et les adieux à la reine et
les adieux à la reine sont de ce point
de vue là à mon avis plus rigoureux
voilà tu plus ribéry sur le plan
historique et sur la psychologie des
personnages d'accord vraiment formidable
insistant justement sur sur le la
douleur or la douleur cette femme a une
vie douloureuse
bien sûr il faut le dire toute la mort
de ses enfants et chez les non abonnés
d'accord et vous alors votre prochain
livre puisque vous m'avez l'air bien
parti dans cette carrière d'écrivain oui
ou à james hodges
l'avenir le dira oui j'ai un projet qui
est déjà fait déjà commencé il ya déjà
quelques dérapages sont écrites alors
écoutez je vais essayer un roman je vais
essayer
sur sur un sujet qui a été à la fois
très traités et peut traiter puisqu'en
fait je voudrais m'intéresser aux
mousquetaires mais pas les mousquetaires
d'alexandre dumas c'est à dire par les
mousquetaires de louis xiii ça s'est un
peu fait je pense que l'on peut pas y
revenir mais sur les mousquetaires à
l'époque de louis 15 or il faut savoir
que le corps des mousquetaires à
l'époque de louis 15e suivait tous les
événements du règne et donc je vais
essayer de cils et pénétrait ce niveau
là exactement découvrir ici les lecteurs
me font l'amitié l'intérêt de bien
vouloir me dire essayer d'écrire quelque
chose là-dessus non moins génial
écoutez ça sera fait j'ai envie de vous
dire rendez vous en novembre oui car
vous serez présent au salon histoire de
lire de versailles absolument avec donc
la biographie du ministre calonne les
avec ce magnifique livre que j'encours à
touba lire même sur la plage d'ailleurs
oui très bien sur l'asile mobile et
c'est distrayant et éducationnel ça se
disent c'est peut-être un barbarisme
mais on va le dire comme à dakar merci
monsieur les infinis robben était à très
vite là notre coeur voir
[Musique]